con vacunas ya o basta de muertes fueron
los lemas de la protesta de las médicas
y enfermeras venezolanas el sábado unas
150 personas en su mayoría profesionales
médicos salieron a las calles para
exigir al gobierno de nicolás maduro un
plan de vacunación sin sesgo político y
que tenga como prioridad al personal
sanitario el líder de la oposición juan
guaidó lideró la marcha en la capital
caracas
[Música]
porque contratamos hoy
medidas de seguridad que siempre
por eso hoy aquí
venezuela también está sumida en una
nueva ola de la pandemia saca la nación
comenzó la vacunación el pasado febrero
no hay reportes de cuántas personas han
sido inoculadas con las dosis rusa
sputnik y la china sino farm que
inicialmente estaban destinadas a los
profesionales de la salud y maestros
pero gremio médico denuncia retrasos no
queremos que la vacuna sea politizada
queremos que la vacuna sea administrada
a toda la población venezolana sin
ningún tipo de exclusión y de control
social
según la ong médicos unidos más de 480
trabajadores sanitarios han fallecido
por el coronavirus pero primero lo que
estamos en la primera línea que somos el
personal de salud estamos en riesgo ya
que muchas veces no tenemos el equipo de
protección personal completo para
atender a nuestros pacientes venezuela
suma más de 180.000 contagios y casi dos
mil decesos unas cifras que muchas
organizaciones consideran que no
muestran la situación real del país
cuyos frágiles hospitales están
saturados y acumulan largas filas para
conseguir oxígeno